[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Joining us today--
I don't think they
need introduction--
but that the powerhouse
team behind State
Bird and The Progress, Stuart
Brioza and Nicole Krasinski.
Welcome to Google.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
STUART BRIOZA: All right.
Thanks.
Awesome.
Well, it's nice to
be here, for sure.
How many of you have
actually eaten at State Bird?
Oh, good-- like a
little less than half.
Perfect.
We're always looking
for more customers.
SPEAKER: I think the
others just probably
couldn't get a reservation,
more than anything.
STUART BRIOZA: Yeah,
well, there's that, too.
And it's a long drive
from Sunnyvale if--
SPEAKER: Well worth
it-- not the problem.
STUART BRIOZA: Well, hopefully,
at the end of this demo,
you'll all be racing and coming
up with your own programs
to hack into our
reservation system
and get yourself a reservation.
SPEAKER: Challenge
accepted, Googlers.
STUART BRIOZA: Yeah.
I'm sure, in this group--
that's actually part of
the history of State Bird.
For some of you, you
probably already know
this, because that stuff
is important to you.
But we were in Australia.
We were doing kind of
a pop-up in Australia.
And I get a call at
3:00 in the morning
from Paolo Lucchesi, who's the
writer for the "San Francisco
Chronicle."
And I'm like, wow,
he's calling me.
It's 3:00 in the morning.
Should I take it?
And I took it, and he starts
just grilling me about, like,
do you know that
you've been hacked
and that people are
making reservations?
And then it grew.
It just continued to grow.
So Paolo calls me.
And then the BBC calls us.
"The New York Times" calls us.
And I'm sort of like, this
isn't a big deal, people.
Like, I don't see
this as a big deal.
This is not a problem for us.
Like, we're OK.
I was like, it
becomes a problem when
people hack into the
reservation system,
and then they don't show up.
Because that's a problem to me.
But humans were coming in.
And they were saying
about robots and all this.
And I was like, I don't know
what you're talking about.
All I know is that we're
packed every night,
and that's a great thing.
And it was sort of like,
what responsibility do I
have in this?
And I was like, I have zero
responsibility in this.
SPEAKER: Stop being so popular?
STUART BRIOZA: Yeah, exactly.
But I think it spawned
off a whole new--
I call it the brave new world
of running a restaurant,
where it's like, OK, I never
thought about that issue.
I deal with, like,
dishwashers calling in sick,
food purveyors--
SPEAKER: We deal with that, too,
if it makes you feel better.
STUART BRIOZA: You do, too.
Yeah.
OK-- real restaurant
issues-- you know,
a sink that's runny or
backs up or something--
never about hacking into
a reservation system--
seems totally out of my league.
Anyway, today, we're
going to demo something
that I think has really turned
into very much a signature
dish at the restaurant, mainly
because it's so unusual.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: And delicious.
STUART BRIOZA: And
very delicious.
SPEAKER: That goes
without saying,
based on my personal
experiences in your restaurants.
STUART BRIOZA: The idea
of this is it's carrots.
And we decided to
make a carrot dish.
I think every chef
in the country
is kind of challenged with
making a carrot dish--
something that becomes
kind of like part
of your roster of dishes.
It's just like everybody's got
kind of a great fried chicken
dish or a great steak dish.
You also, as a chef, have
to have a great carrot dish.
At least it feels that way.
So our great carrot dish is to
do a kind of a carrot four-way,
right, where we make
a mochi out of this.
And you've probably
all had mochi,
but you've never
had a savory mochi.
And it makes so much sense.
And I look at it as, this
mochi-- our carrot mochi--
is akin and a distant cousin
to the potato gnocchi in Italy.
So it's really like that.
It's that same idea.
The beauty of it is that
we're not using flour,
so there's no gluten in it.
But we are using a starchy,
glutenous rice flour
to bind it.
It's also got a huge
margin for error.
Where gnocchi are
so temperamental,
and you've got to have the right
starch content in your potato,
you've got to have
the right balance,
timing is such a critical,
these are virtually foolproof.
I mean, you can cook your
carrot puree the day before
and make your mochi the day of.
So there's not a lot of--
there's a big margin for
error, which is always nice,
I mean, I think, even
for home cooking.
And it's really
awesome with kids.
So if you have kids--
we have a kid.
Of course, he doesn't
eat anything like this.
SPEAKER: Oh, the irony!
STUART BRIOZA: But
other people's kids
seem to really love this dish
when they come to restaurant.
As a matter of fact, we tend to,
when we go on to visit friends,
and we're staying with them,
their kids will be like,
can we make mochi?
I mean, they'll ask this.
And then I'll teach them.
And we'll do a little
improv cooking class.
So let's kind of
get this started.
I've taken the liberty of
getting my carrots cooked.
I'm just going to crank this up.
The idea is that I just cook
carrots in boiling water--
organic-- the sweetest
carrots you can find.
Just a little salt. So I'm
going to bring this up.
And they're really tender.
And how you gauge that is, do
they fall apart in your hands?
And I don't always encourage
people to put your hands
in boiling water.
But that's what happens
when you become a chef.
You become immune to these
ideas of boiling water.
So these are done now.
And I'm going to
take them and just
strain them out in a colander.
And I want to intensify
the carrot flavor.
So this is kind of the trick.
We could stop here.
And we could just kind
of puree these carrots.
Or we could do what I'm going
to do next, which is basically
intensify the carrot flavor by
putting this back on the stove.
Let's make sure these
induction burners are--
is it going?
I think it is.
I feel it.
Oh, yes.
I'm going to add carrot juice
to this-- so fresh carrot
juice added to these carrots.
And I'm going to kind of
do it little by little.
So I'm going to reduce it in.
And I'm going to concentrate
and basically sweeten up
the flavor.
The idea is just to get the most
carrot flavor into my mochi.
Otherwise, they will just
look like orange balls.
But if I can get more
and infuse more flavor,
it's really helpful.
While this is going, I'm going
to kind of roast the carrot.
So as I said, it's
a carrot four-way.
And so in a pan, with butter--
and don't be afraid
to use butter.
[LAUGHTER]
Seriously, you laugh.
Don't be.
This is why our
restaurant is so good.
[LAUGHTER]
But what I'm going to do
is, I'm going to just throw
my carrots right into here.
I may not use all of these.
I try to find some
different sizes.
And I'm going to take a
couple of garlic cloves.
And I like to keep
them in the skin.
And what I'll do is,
I just smash them.
You can just kind
of take a knife.
And I just want
to crack the skin.
And I want to get just a
little flavor that comes out.
And I like to use the skin.
There's nothing
wrong with the skin.
Don't be afraid of the skin.
And I'm going to
take some rosemary.
And I'm just going to throw a
couple of sprigs of rosemary
in here, a good crack of pepper.
I, of course, like
to use a pepper mill.
It just kind of makes sense.
And then-- oops, pardon me--
a good pinch of salt. And don't
be afraid to use salt either.
That's another secret to why
our restaurants are so good.
Now, you can smell that?
Can you get that?
[LAUGHTER]
So soon enough, you'll get that.
And I'm going to
turn the heat down,
because I don't want
to roast it too hot.
But I do want the
butter to brown.
And notice I didn't
brown my butter first.
You don't need to.
You can actually brown it
in the process of doing it.
And I'm just going to assume
that that's going to be good,
and I'm going to
keep that going.
Pardon my reach here.
And notice that
Nicole just keeps
adding more carrot juice to the
pot and we keep reducing it.
And our goal here
is just to make
a real tight, concentrated
blob of a mass.
"Blob" is a culinary
term for anything
that sort of moves
in "blobular" motion.
So these take a while to cook.
You could roast
them in the oven,
or you can just do the
whole thing on stovetop.
And you see how it gets
foamy and buttery there?
Can you see all that?
That's the magic that's
happening to the carrots.
And that's the browning of it.
And so now I just want to manage
it and kind of keep it going.
Cool.
Feel free to ask questions
as we're going, too.
I'm sort of not like, save
your questions to the end.
If something just inspires
you immediately, just like--
ah-- jolt it out.
SPEAKER: The only
dorky thing is I
have to repeat them for
the people who watch it
on the live stream later.
So yes, Andre?
AUDIENCE: Do you ever
use the pressure cooker
method [INAUDIBLE]?
SPEAKER: Oh, do you
use a pressure cooker
method to caramelize?
STUART BRIOZA: No, to
answer your question.
But that doesn't
sound like a bad idea.
For the carrot
puree to just-- or--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it brings
out a nuttier, more--
STUART BRIOZA: How interesting.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: Or
for the brown butter.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
STUART BRIOZA: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I haven't, no.
But not that I wouldn't
think that's a great idea.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: We do
use a pressure cooker
quite a lot for other things.
STUART BRIOZA: That's right.
Yeah.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: Yeah.
STUART BRIOZA: Yeah, we
do use pressure cookers
for kind of extractions,
more or less.
I'll throw whole fish into
it-- like, whole cod-- and I'll
make fish stock in
a pressure cooker.
And it's totally wild and crazy.
But it really extracts all
the gelatins out of it.
We'll do a French onion soup
in a pressure cooker, where
we caramelize our
onions, and then we'll
put the onions into a pressure
cooker with onion stock.
And then we'll turn it
on, and we'll let it go.
And sometimes, I've put
gruyere in the pressure cooker
with the onions.
And it was pretty cool.
I mean, it's some neat things.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
STUART BRIOZA: Yeah.
I think that what
I like about it is
that you don't lose any liquid.
You retain everything.
So everything that
goes in is everything
that's coming out, too.
However, in this case, we want
to encourage the reduction
because we're concentrating the
sugars and the sweet flavors
in it.
But good question.
Cool.
Those books are
just way too big.
AUDIENCE: I made
it to [INAUDIBLE]..
STUART BRIOZA: You
made it to-- yeah.
They're impressive.
SPEAKER: It's a lifelong journey
through "Modernist Cuisine,"
I think.
They came out with
"Modernist Baking" now.
I've tacked on many years to my
life to get through that one.
STUART BRIOZA: All right.
So we're almost there on this--
making a totally great blob.
And as it just gets
tightened up there,
you can really smell the
concentration of carrots.
And you're just getting
such a nice flavor there.
Other mochis that
we've done as well--
I think color plays
an important role.
So we did a caramelized
onion and rosemary
mochi that tasted great, but
it didn't look so beautiful.
But there's other
things that we've done
that have had great success.
So like a pumpkin
or a squash mochi--
winter squash, where
you roast, and you
get that bright, vivid color.
And then when you mix
in the mochi flour,
it works the same way.
And when you cook
them, they look just
like the same
color of a pumpkin.
So this recipe is totally
transferable to other things--
as many things as you
want to kind of try.
I would totally encourage you to
make the carrot version first.
So what I'm going to do
is, I want to take this--
and you can see how
it's really tight--
SPEAKER: "Blobular,"
if you will.
STUART BRIOZA:
Glob, with texture.
Let's see here.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: Are
you done with that guy?
STUART BRIOZA: I think
I'm done with this.
I'm just going to puree it.
I like the texture
of carrot in there.
So it's not imperative
that it's very smooth.
But it's OK if it's very smooth.
I kind of think like the
texture of rice, maybe--
the coarseness of broken rice--
is a good way to think about it.
Cool.
And now what I'm going to do--
one of the most
important steps here
is, I am going to weigh it out.
There is a recipe,
and it tells you
how much to use, of
course, because that's
what recipe books do.
But basically, we like
to work in ratios.
And so I've got this
nice carrot puree.
And I'm getting 500.
And I know I brought a
pound of mochi flour.
So I start with
one-to-one ratio.
I usually end up adding
a little bit more.
So there's 454 grams.
I'll just go 400 to
give myself a little--
and again, it's whatever
you want to make.
I mean, we make this
in 2,500-gram batches,
is kind of the idea.
And then what I'll
do is, since I've
got about 400 grams right here.
And I'll add another 400
grams or so of mochi flour.
And that will be
my starting point.
Perfect.
And being that I'm
adding a lot of flour,
I'm going to add just a nice
pinch of salt into there.
AUDIENCE: 2,500
would be [INAUDIBLE]??
STUART BRIOZA: [LAUGHS] Yeah.
Boy, 2,500-- so that's about
five pounds of mochi, right?
But we're making
two pounds of mochi.
It would last is about a
night's worth of service.
This is one of our most
popular dishes, for sure,
outside of the quail, of course.
But people just love this dish.
It's a hard one for
us to take off, now,
because it's so unusual.
And it's just a
slam dunk everyday.
People eat it, and
nobody's like, oh,
whoa, that's a weird texture.
They're eating it
and going, wow,
I never thought carrots
could actually taste so good.
And this is really unusual.
And it's that
thing that's like--
it's familiar, but
it's different.
And that's one of the
philosophies of State Bird,
is that we try to work
within the familiar,
but we want to do something
that's just a little different.
We do a fried quail in lieu
of doing fried chicken.
But the idea was inspired
from fried chicken, of course.
We make mochi
instead of gnocchi.
We do--
NICOLE KRASINSKI:
Ice cream sandwiches
that aren't ice cream.
STUART BRIOZA: Ice
cream sandwiches
that aren't ice cream--
but they are.
But they're not.
But they are.
That's an argument that
we continue to have.
This is one of my favorite
dishes, and it's in the book.
We do an amatriciana.
Do you guys know amatriciana?
Anyone?
You're nodding your head.
I'm going to put
you on the spot.
What is it?
AUDIENCE: Tomato, sometimes
onion, and guanciale.
STUART BRIOZA: You got it.
Yeah.
So it's a Roman dish.
It's a Roman pasta dish
that's made with guanciale,
which is cured pork jowl.
And so it's got a
lot of pepper to it.
And it's like pancetta.
But it's using this
portion of the pork.
It is magic.
And it's one of my
all-time favorite dishes
ever to be made in the world.
And it's really kind
of a nice tomato sauce.
You start off rendering
out your guanciale.
You add your tomato sauce
and you add rigatoni
and you had lots of
pecorino and black pepper.
And that's the dish.
Well, we riff off of that.
And we take guanciale.
We render it out.
And we add a little
garlic and some chilies.
We add a little
chanterelle to it.
We add fresh tomato sauce
from fresh heirloom tomatoes.
So this is something we
only do in the summer.
And then we use tofu skin--
yuba-- as our noodles for this.
So we totally spin
it on its ear.
Because I think anyone's Italian
grandmother would beat me
to a pulp with a wooden
spoon in the kitchen
if they knew that I was using--
I mean, first if I was using
fresh tomatoes in amatriciana,
in something beyond
just rigatoni.
But the fact that
it's tofu skin--
but it's magic.
And when you eat the dish,
it tastes like amatriciana.
But it's familiar,
but different.
And so that is what we do.
So what I'm looking
for here in my dough
is just something
about this consistency.
It's a little tight.
It's also a little tacky to it.
But it can hold its shape,
not unlike Play-Doh.
But there is a nice
tackiness to it.
And so for this, what we
would do is, we'd make balls.
And so I'm going to have
Nicole make some little mochi
balls there.
I'm going to really
put myself to the test
because I generally always
have a pot of water going,
and I do my little tester.
But I'm so confident today that
I don't need to do a tester.
SPEAKER: Living dangerously.
I like it.
STUART BRIOZA: Yeah.
That's something in the kitchen.
It's like, if we make
a sausage or a dough
or anything of that sort,
we always make a tester.
We just want to make sure
that the seasoning's right,
that the texture is right.
And so if any adjustments
need to be made,
it's not after you've
portioned 150 balls
and you have to put them
back in and remake it.
So while that's going,
I'm going to turn
the heat back on on this.
And you see our carrots are
just kind of moving away.
And they're gorgeous.
They're not quite there yet.
So we'll just let
them kind of finish.
I'm gonna turn that heat up.
The next step in
our process here--
oh, you know what?
I used my bowl here.
Let me see if I can do this.
SPEAKER: I'm certain we
have another bowl for you.
STUART BRIOZA: Are you sure?
I'm OK with repurposing.
SPEAKER: Positive-- it's
literally right here!
STUART BRIOZA: OK.
SPEAKER: Thank you, Jared.
STUART BRIOZA: Thank you.
So this is the third component.
It's going to be
our vinaigrette.
And so because we've
got roasted carrots,
we've got pickled carrots, which
I'll go into in just a minute,
and then we've got
the carrot mochi,
we want to reintroduce another
fresh component into it.
So this is just
fresh carrot juice
that becomes the basis of
our carrot vinaigrette.
And to that, what
I'm going to do
is I'm going to add fresh lime.
I like to kind of massage
my lime up a little bit.
And I'm just going to
squeeze lime juice into this.
I'm going purely by
taste here, you guys.
I feel pretty confident that
I've got that part nailed.
And I'm just going
to juice a lime.
Next, the microplane
comes in handy.
And this is going
to blow your minds.
So I think that microplanes
are about the best tool ever
to be created in the kitchen.
And I'll show you why--
because it can replace
everything you own.
All right.
So I use a microplane
to grate ginger.
And I feel that
what I get out of it
is I get a great disbursement
of ginger flavor.
And you can see it
underneath there.
And it really takes it
down to such a ground mass
that it works great.
I use a microplane
to grate garlic.
And I'll take a clove of garlic.
And I don't use a lot.
A little garlic goes a long way.
You can always add more.
This is the mindblowing part.
I use a microplane to
grate fresh chilies.
It comes with a nice sound,
too, like you're actually
grating something.
And you never know how
spicy your chilies are.
Woo!
So I'll add a little bit
of ground chili into it.
The chili thing
really blows my mind.
I love doing this.
SPEAKER: I've never
seen that before.
STUART BRIOZA: Yeah.
See?
SPEAKER: Stealing that.
STUART BRIOZA: And then what
we're going to do is we're
going to add just a
little fresh black pepper,
a pinch of salt to this.
And then we're going
to kind of make
an oil slick of extra
virgin olive oil.
Stir this whole thing around.
And now we've got this super
vibrant carrot vinaigrette.
We taste everything.
I think it needs more acid.
The garlic is amazing.
The ginger comes through.
I'm getting a little heat.
I think I kind of want a
little more heat in there.
But this is how we do it.
You constantly are
tasting for what you want.
I'm going to put a little
more ginger in there.
Ginger and carrot is just one
of the magical combinations,
as you probably know already.
A little more ginger, a
little more jalapeno--
what I love about the
jalapeno by doing this,
is that you really
don't get the seeds.
Let's go fresh spoon.
There it is.
So what I'm looking
for there is,
I want to taste
the carrot juice.
But I want to taste all of the
other ingredients-- the garlic,
the ginger, the jalapeno.
I want to have a nice little
kind of slick of olive oil
that adds the fat to it.
And I also want to just
make sure that the lime--
the acid and salt
is really balanced.
Not one should
overpower the other.
And that's how we do that.
Cool.
So these carrots are
just doing really well.
And I'm running out
of stove space here.
But we're going to just
take it really quick.
So the last part of this dish--
now we've got our
carrot juice vin.
We're going to make the duqqa.
And duqqa is just kind of
a cumin-based spice blend
that we can use in
the mortar and pestle.
And we do a pistachio duqqa.
We want that nuttiness
from the pistachios.
So here, I am going
to let these guys--
what I'm going to do is
turn it up really well.
This is so good.
I love carrots when
they're just slow
cooked in butter like this.
You see what's happening?
I mean, just like magic
over time is just happening.
AUDIENCE: Is that camera
pointed at the stove?
STUART BRIOZA: I don't know.
Can we see?
No?
OK.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: You have to
hold it over the cutting board.
STUART BRIOZA: Oh, the
camera is not there?
NICOLE KRASINSKI:
It's right there.
SPEAKER: It's this one.
It's that one.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: So it's
right over where you're-- yeah,
right there.
No, down, down, down,
down, down, down.
SPEAKER: Down a little bit.
Down a little bit.
Ta-da!
STUART BRIOZA: Oh, there it is.
Oh, I see it.
OK.
Can you guys see that?
Yeah, that's gorgeous.
Wonderful.
[LAUGHS] Well, now that we
got that part out of the way--
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
is well aware.
STUART BRIOZA: Cool.
All right.
I'm going to pull
that off, and they're
going to just continue
to simmer there.
Meanwhile, what
I'm going to do is,
I'm going add everything here--
whole coriander seeds, cumin.
I'm going to add
sesame to this mix.
I've already pre-toasted
my pistachios.
I've got chili flakes
and I've got sea salt.
I do not want to
toast my chili flakes.
If I did, all of you out
there would start sneezing
and have eye irritation.
But I'll work over a nice
high heat and bring this up.
And as soon as I can kind
of see little wisps of smoke
is where I know it's done.
And I'm going to place it right
into the mortar and pestle.
SPEAKER: What other dishes do
you find you cannot take off
your menu?
STUART BRIOZA: Oh,
well, let's see here.
SPEAKER: Aside from the
State Bird, of course.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: Pork belly.
SPEAKER: Yeah, that pork belly.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: Probably
pork belly with citrus--
fish sauce vin.
SPEAKER: Yes.
STUART BRIOZA: Yep.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: Some
people have it for dessert.
SPEAKER: Next time.
STUART BRIOZA: Next time.
The garlic bread with burrata.
SPEAKER: Ooh, that one
was transformative.
STUART BRIOZA: Yeah, see?
You guys just did it.
That's why we can't take
it off, right there.
We've got that dialed out.
We sell about 70
of those a night.
And we serve about
200 people a night.
SPEAKER: That's one that
comes by too late in the meal.
And you're like,
but I ate so much,
but I have to eat
the garlic bread.
AUDIENCE: Where do
you get the burrata?
STUART BRIOZA: So
the burrata that we
use is from one of the original
burrata makers in the US.
And they're down in LA.
Gioia is the name.
I asked him once--
I was like, so
what's your process?
And he was like, seriously?
It's the one thing
I make and I'm
going to give you my secrets?
SPEAKER: Hey, you've
got a question here?
AUDIENCE: What are
some dishes you wish
you could get off the menu?
SPEAKER: Oh, what
are some dishes
you wish you could that you--
do you constrain yourself?
The sky's the limit?
STUART BRIOZA: Not at all.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: That's why
we have a second restaurant.
STUART BRIOZA: Yeah.
There you go.
There aren't really any
dishes that we wish we could.
Because State Bird is based
around and it's built around
cook-what-you-want, and
the freedom of cooking.
The one thing that I
always say about our food
there is it has to be shareable.
So I wouldn't put, like, a
steak on a plate and serve it.
It's shareable, but
we keep people moving.
We keep the evening--
the dinner service-- moving.
And we want to make sure
that it is as user-friendly
as possible--
all of our food.
And we think about that.
How can I get more food on your
table, is what I think about.
And you think about, how can
I get more food in my stomach?
So it's a team effort.
And it's symbiotic.
So do you see these
little wisps of smoke.
You can see that as I'm--
NICOLE KRASINSKI: There you go.
SPEAKER: Hey!
STUART BRIOZA: Yeah, I got it.
We got it.
And what I'm doing is, I'm just
bringing those flavors out.
Now, some of you can smell that.
Just wait.
Let's put that back on.
I'm gonna add some
sea salt to this--
a nice pinch.
I'm gonna add my
chili flakes because I
do kind of want them to have
a little intensity, though.
I'm going to add some
pistachios to this mix.
And now, I hope this works.
SPEAKER: Will you guys
share a little bit
about the inspiration for the
restaurant in the first place?
It's so unique.
NICOLE KRASINSKI:
It's a long story.
SPEAKER: It's a beautiful story.
It's in the book.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: It is.
SPEAKER: But short version?
NICOLE KRASINSKI: Sure.
SPEAKER: Inspiration, drivers?
NICOLE KRASINSKI: Yeah.
We never intended
to open State Bird.
So we had written
a business plan.
We had raised money for
what is now The Progress,
and had found a space,
were ready to go,
and the space fell through.
So we were like, well, shit.
And we found out, also,
we were having a baby.
SPEAKER: Ta-da!
NICOLE KRASINSKI:
So we really felt
like we needed to
get jobs quickly.
So we had been focusing on one
neighborhood in San Francisco.
And we told our broker,
just look everywhere.
Look in all the places we
never wanted to look before.
And a week after our son was
born, she was like, well,
I have this place on Fillmore,
which I know you don't like.
But I think you
should go look at it.
SPEAKER: Across from
the Panda Express.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: That's right--
across from the Panda Express,
in the Safeway parking lot.
STUART BRIOZA: And a Subway.
SPEAKER: Western
Addition, y'all.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: Stuart rode
his bike down there and--
STUART BRIOZA: Can you
smell this, by the way?
NICOLE KRASINSKI: --walked
into this dark purple, grease
trap-smelling, not very
beautiful, tiny space.
The whole building was vacant--
10,000 square feet.
And then the landlord
took him into this space
that's now The Progress
with the huge arching
ceilings from the old movie
theater that was built in 1911.
And we were like, this
is where we want to be.
You could be
anywhere in the city.
You don't see anything
outside those windows.
But you have skylights.
And it was the
restaurant we wanted.
But it would cost a lot
and take a lot of time
because it had never
been a restaurant.
STUART BRIOZA: And we
needed to make money.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: And
we needed to make money.
STUART BRIOZA: We had a kid now.
And we were running out of time.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: Yeah.
So we went back that night
and said to each other,
what if we take both spaces?
And the landlord was
thinking the same thing
at that same time.
So we signed two leases
at once, but then
had to come up
with a new business
plan and a whole new concept.
So in a few weeks, we sort
of visualized State Bird,
thinking that it would be just
a really fast thing to open,
and then we could move on
to the dream restaurant.
And then things
unraveled differently.
AUDIENCE: Funny how
that works, isn't it?
STUART BRIOZA: Yeah, so State
Bird, we literally winged it.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: That's my kind of joke.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
dim-sum-- American dim sum?
SPEAKER: Yeah, why
American dim sum, which--
PS-- is the best idea ever.
STUART BRIOZA: Yeah.
In the early days, people
would say, god, why
didn't I think of this?
You know, it was one of those.
SPEAKER: And nobody has
really ripped it off,
which is surprising.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: It's not easy.
People have tried.
STUART BRIOZA: There's been
a little bit of some people
who've adopted certain ways.
And I think that
that's kind of more
the interesting idea
rather than ripping it off.
It's actually a lot
harder than people think.
And those who have
tried to rip it off
have had a very tough go of it.
SPEAKER: Well,
serves them right.
STUART BRIOZA: And that's OK.
I mean, I think that it's OK to
have multiple of restaurants.
But it's also really
nice and reassuring.
What we do works because
we've really made it work.
And the idea of it came about--
during the time that we were
looking to open a restaurant,
we did a lot of
private catering gigs.
And they were really
by word of mouth.
We were caterers out of
our little 900-square-foot
apartment in San Francisco.
And we started to get a lot of
requests for people who wanted
to have an informal
dinner party,
but still liked really
creative food and lots of fun,
and nobody wants to sit down--
so just like a cocktail party--
and kitchens--
nice home kitchens
that had a nice little island.
And it would be kind
of a walk-around event.
And so rather than just doing
an hors d'oeuvres party,
these became like 11,
12, to 15-item hors
d'oeuvres parties--
so almost like a
coursed-out dinner.
And one of the events, we
even hired a friend who
was a sommelier at Gary Danko.
And he went around,
and he'd just
be splashing people
with wine all night
and talking about the
wine and the food.
And it was super cool.
And we had a great
time doing this.
And we were able to take
a little more risks,
because when you're serving
three or four dishes,
everybody wants the safe items--
the things that are
going to be popular,
like garlic bread with
burrata or crab cakes.
But this particular party
that we sort of took it
to the next level was, we were
serving lamb tongue on toast,
and doing things that
were like, well, we built
that relationship through
the other safer items,
and people would come
back, and I'd say,
well, it's pickled lamb.
And some people, I would tell
them it was tongue, and others,
I would say it was just lamb.
But it looked good.
It looked beautiful
on the plate.
And we eat first with our eyes.
And I was able to talk
people into eating food.
And the buy-in was small--
one bite.
So you've got to think
about real estate.
And so we applied
that same idea.
And it really matched the
idea as chefs at the time
that we wanted to create
a restaurant where
we could cook what we want
and have lots of freedom
and flexibility, and
not necessarily have
a specific regional calling.
We're not a northern
Italian restaurant.
We're not a Chinese restaurant.
We've always been
challenged-- and I
think a lot of American chefs
are challenged thoroughly--
by how to define
themselves as chefs.
Like, well, what is it?
When people ask me, like,
what is it, the food you cook?
It's really tough.
Well, I do this
American dim sum.
It's like California cuisine.
And really, you look
at our menu and you
look at the demographics
of the Bay Area,
and it's a lot of
Asian influence
and a lot of Mexican influence
and some thorough American
ingenuity with some European.
So it's a little
bit of everything.
And what I like to
actually call that cuisine
is this evolved
California cuisine.
We're in a state of
evolution and evolving
what California cuisine really
is to the people who live here.
And of course, we're born
and raised in this area.
So we have a pretty good
understanding of it.
But to answer your question, we
were doing this kind of thing,
and we looked at
the kitchen that
was in the front
of the restaurant,
and I kind of thought about
ducks hanging in the window.
And I was like, wow, you've
got cooks right there,
preparing the food.
And you enter, and the
first thing you're doing
is you're entering
through the kitchen--
it feels that way because
the kitchen's right there
and the dining
room's in the back.
And it all kind of
just made sense.
And we just put the
pieces together.
And that's it.
Yeah.
And people would say,
oh, great concept.
And I was like, what are
you talking about, man?
This is my restaurant.
This is not a concept.
This is our heart and
soul and our passion
and our love for cooking
and teaching and interacting
with people--
the people who are coming in--
to have an experience
that was different
than at other restaurants.
We looked at it that we're
all one world in the kitchen.
We get to talk to the guests.
And the guests get to talk.
And you know that
feeling you get
when you're sitting
at a counter,
and you're watching the
sushi chefs preparing,
and you're talking.
And you create this rapport.
And so it was really
imperative to have that for us.
We wanted to know the people
we were cooking for, too.
We want to have
that relationship.
We want to not have
it be like dining
room, kitchen, separation.
And we talk about that all
the time-- front of the house,
back of the house.
Well, it applies
to diners as well.
So anyway, that's kind of it.
And it really gave
us the ability
to do whatever we
wanted in the kitchen.
As long as it tastes good,
looks good, it works.
So that's it.
All right.
I say, let's put
this dish together.
So our carrots
are nice and soft.
And you can see that
just in their shape.
And what I'm going to
do is I'm going to throw
some butter into the pan.
And at the same time, you
want to drop about 10 of those
into the simmering water
that's been salted.
You guys saw me do that.
I'm going to take a
couple of these carrots.
You can leave them
whole, but I'm
going to cut them up
just a little bit.
Oh, yeah.
These are perfect.
And then I'm going to
take some pickled carrots.
And the pickled carrots are just
a baby carrot that we pickle.
And the recipe's included.
But it's a vinegar pickle.
So this is not a
fermented pickle.
And what we like to do is
shave them really thin.
You can use a knife
for that or a mandolin.
But if you've got the
knife skills, apply it.
NICOLE KRASINSKI:
And a sharp knife.
STUART BRIOZA:
That's what I say.
And so the idea of having a
pickle in a dish like this
really makes a lot of sense.
It adds nice texture contrast.
It also adds a nice refreshing
acidic balance to it.
A couple of different
colors here.
AUDIENCE: Do you use a sweeter
vinegar, or do you use--
STUART BRIOZA: We do
sweeten the vinegar.
So we use, for this
one, rice vinegar.
And we use salt
and a little sugar
and some spices as well into it.
And we pickle them whole.
And then every day,
we'll cut them.
We'll take them out
of a big pickle crock,
and we'll cut them, just
as I'm doing it right now.
I think part of it
is just showcasing
carrots in different forms--
whole form, juiced form,
prepared form, and then
rounds--
pickled, where we
cut it in rounds.
So you get a real good
environmental scape
of the carrots, if
that makes sense.
AUDIENCE: Why vinegar
instead of lacto-ferment?
STUART BRIOZA:
Because we didn't want
that lacto-fermented
flavor to it.
So we do a ton of
lacto-fermenting
at the restaurant, whether
it's sauerkrauts or kimchis
or we'll do a dill
carrot, dill pickles.
And we do that.
But this one, we wanted
it to be sweeter,
and just we wanted the vinegar
flavor, which, of course, is
its own scent of taking it.
Yeah, we wanted a brightness
to it without quite the salt,
if that makes sense.
Cool.
So these guys are
done when they float.
And if you can see,
which you can't--
can we get one of
those moving orbs--
they're not floating yet.
Yeah.
So just like a gnocchi
or any kind of dumpling,
we would take it and--
boil, boil boil!
And what I've done here
is, I'm browning my butter.
This time, I want
my butter brown
when I add my dumplings to it.
So the idea of browning butter
is just that it pulls out
a nuttiness out of the butter.
How you know it's brown is
when it stops crackling.
So all the milk solids have
cooked and tightened up
and cooked out.
And then you'll start to
see little particles, which
is those browning.
And that's how you
get the brown butter.
And I have it on
a nice low temp.
So I can hold this
for a minute here.
SPEAKER: Other questions while
we wait for the mochi to float?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why did you keep
the peel on the garlic?
SPEAKER: Why did you keep
STUART BRIOZA: Ah,
that's a good question.
It acts as a little
shield, and the garlic
doesn't brown too fast.
It's browned.
It's browned in a nice way--
a way that I actually love
eating garlic right there.
But it acts as a little
shield-- a barrier.
So if you had the raw
garlic to the pan,
you're still getting the
same qualities of it.
But when I'm slow
cooking or long cooking,
I want that garlic
to not get bitter,
and I want it to
caramelize slowly.
So that little barrier
is really important.
Cool.
Anyone else?
No?
NICOLE KRASINSKI: You can do
this step and then chill them--
STUART BRIOZA: Oh, yes.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: --and
cook them later, right?
STUART BRIOZA: So
great, great, great.
This is another part of
that great margin for error.
And also, from an entertaining
perspective, and something
that the team here
at Google has done,
is that you take them to
this, and you can actually
cook them, boil them, and then
refresh them under cold water,
rub them in a little
oil, and put them
in the fridge for later.
And then when
you're ready to go,
you can take them
right out of the fridge
and put them into your
pan with brown butter
and just kind of slowly
cook them and reheat them.
So that's another great
thing, is that you
can do a lot of this ahead.
And so now that these
guys are floating--
you can see they just kind
of come up like any dumpling.
I like to think these are like
our carrot matsu balls, right?
I'll just take a slotted
spoon, and I'm just
going to place them right in.
And like the carrots, I
love all that brown butter.
So I'm going to add a little
salt and a good crack of pepper
to it.
And what I'm trying to do
is, I want to brown these
off a little bit.
And they look so good.
We'll go on high.
AUDIENCE: I've got a question.
STUART BRIOZA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What are you
serving for Super Bowl Sunday?
SPEAKER: What are you serving
for Super Bowl Sunday?
STUART BRIOZA: That's
a good question.
You know, every year, the
kitchens, they team up.
They should go
opposites, I guess.
But they do team up between
State Bird and The Progress,
and they do a huge Super
Bowl Sunday spread.
It's kind of insane.
NICOLE KRASINSKI:
But for family meal.
STUART BRIOZA: But
for family meal.
Yeah.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: Our
menus don't change.
But our staff, they have fun.
They make chicken wings.
STUART BRIOZA: Yeah.
Like, Thursday and Friday, I'll
start seeing the wings come in.
And we really want them to cook
well and do fun things, too.
And so they do kind
of an insane spread.
All the holidays and all
the specialty cooking days,
the kitchens go insane.
And they're kind of the
best days to be working.
I think people come in on
their days off, actually--
SPEAKER: I would.
STUART BRIOZA: --just
to come in and eat.
Yeah.
So we do the classics--
wings, bleu cheese,
lots of chip and dip.
So I'm reintroducing the
carrots back into this.
And I've really
browned that nicely.
And then let's see here.
I'm going to use
an unslotted spoon.
And really, I'm just
looking for a little color.
The more color
you get on these--
and you can see--
look at their buoyancy there.
They really hold up nicely.
Can you see that?
Back to the camera.
So you can see this buoyancy.
SPEAKER: Yeah,
they're really bouncy.
STUART BRIOZA: Yeah.
They've got a good
bounciness to them.
And right about this
point, I'm going
to spoon a few of these
right into a bowl.
Some of my carrots--
AUDIENCE: What kind
of butter do you use?
SPEAKER: What kind
STUART BRIOZA: I use just a
very plain, unsalted butter.
And that's it.
We work with a local dairy.
NICOLE KRASINSKI:
Out of Petaluma.
STUART BRIOZA: Out of Petaluma.
But that's our goal
with butter, is just
a plain, unsalted butter.
You can always add
salt. It's just
kind of the cleanest version.
And then I'm going to put a
little bit of this butter right
over the top.
Don't be afraid of butter.
We talked about that already.
SPEAKER: The air is
thick with butter scent
in the room at this moment.
STUART BRIOZA: That's right.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: It smells glorious.
STUART BRIOZA: It
smells really good.
So I'm going to take
some gorgeous herbs.
So things that are very
complementary to carrot
are mint, dill.
We have a little
bit of wood sorrel.
You may see this around.
It's in season, and it's wild.
Let's see here.
First, I going to take a little
bit of this pistachio duqqa,
and I'm going to give
a nice dusting to it.
Then I'm going to add some of
my pickled carrots all over.
Of course, we want to
show off the colors.
So I sort of smother
it in pickled carrots.
And then I'm going to add some
of my herbs, which is the mint.
There's red-veined
sorrel, dill, as I said.
And then I'm going to
finish the dish up.
And I'm going to spoon over
the carrot juice vinaigrette.
And I kind of want
enough of the vinaigrette
that it's like a sauce on the
bottom, where I can see it.
And that's about it.
SPEAKER: It's gorgeous.
STUART BRIOZA: There you go.
[APPLAUSE]
STUART BRIOZA: Looks good.
Cool.
Yeah.
It looks good, right?
SPEAKER: Yeah, it's amazing.
STUART BRIOZA: You guys
in the front, hold back.
SPEAKER: It looks
and smells amazing.
I know that our team is
working on some delicious
tastes for you all.
Are there more
questions while we wait?
STUART BRIOZA: Yeah?
SPEAKER: Yeah, wow.
AUDIENCE: What other exciting
future projects do you have?
SPEAKER: Ooh, what's coming?
What future projects
do you have?
Inside scoop, inside scoop.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: We
were actually talking
about that on the drive here.
It's a good time
to meet in the car.
There's no distraction.
STUART BRIOZA: It's an
interesting question.
And it's not easy to answer.
Because I don't totally
have the answer.
And my mind, it's relentless
in the ideas that I want to do.
But I'm also really about trying
to build the most solid company
that we can that's got
incredible culture.
And State Bird started
as 14 employees,
including Nicole and I.
And now, with The Progress,
we're up to about just
under 100 employees.
Both restaurants have
about 50 employees each.
And in a restaurant world,
it's a lot to see and oversee.
And State Bird is now six years
old and Progress is three.
And we're about ready
to start thinking
about that next project.
I've been pushing back.
And we've had lots of
really wonderful offers.
You know, take State
Bird to New York.
Take it to Vegas, LA, Tokyo.
And I'm like, it sounds awesome.
And it's kind of the
dream when people
start coming to you with
real ideas and real dreams.
You're like, yeah, I've
been dreaming of this moment
my entire career.
And then you're like, whoa.
Back up.
It's actually not
as easy as that.
And we have a lot of complexity
built into our restaurants.
We have a farm
that is biodynamic.
We grow all these
little greens and a lot
of the carrots and things
that you see in this dish.
And that's been an
amazing project.
So rather than
grow up, we've been
able to kind of add and
kind of grow wide and create
a lot of really
interesting pieces
that add value to
what we do every day.
And that has been probably the
biggest source of inspiration--
to continue to add and
create this kind of mega-ship
of this culinary building
because we're all
under one roof.
Within that project, we have
a whole fermentation program,
I suppose.
We do a lot of charcuterie.
We do whole animal butchery.
These things get done in
our commissary kitchen,
which is just above State
Bird and The Progress.
And we can take a whole
pig, and certain pieces
go to State Bird, certain
go to The Progress.
So we've got this really
amazing cat's cradle
of a matrix inside our own
building where things are used.
This is one that we just
launched with the cookbook--
State Bird Seed.
It's a partnership with
some very intelligent food
scientists and
restaurant people, food
people, who were all
born out of really
high-quality restaurants--
places like The French Laundry,
Momofuku, Single Thread
up in Healdsburg.
So this is their first project
under the [? Render ?] brand,
where it's a chef-to-shelf
kind of thing.
And so we're really
focused on this.
We're actually hoping to see
it here at Google, for example,
in the snacks.
SPEAKER: Yes, I'm going to
try to get into the MKs.
Absolutely.
STUART BRIOZA: We're
putting a lot of pressure.
SPEAKER: No, not pressure.
Excitement.
STUART BRIOZA: It's
not meant to be that.
It's really delicious.
And it's something we make.
And there's recipes
for it in the cookbook.
NICOLE KRASINSKI:
But it is something
you can buy now online.
You can order it through
Good Eggs, Mollie Stone's.
Rainbow and Bi-Rite, both
in the city, have it.
So there's three flavors.
We only have two up here.
But yeah, it's really snackable.
SPEAKER: I'm going to
start working and as soon
as I get back from this event.
STUART BRIOZA: So I guess
that's it right now.
The other ideas are--
I gotta keep them--
people start talking.
I got to keep it under wraps
until we're ready to unveil.
SPEAKER: The press gets wind.
STUART BRIOZA: Yes?
SPEAKER: Have you
received blowback
about the not-authentic dim
sum cultural appropriation
perspective?
STUART BRIOZA: I think like
any restaurant and any sort
of public entity,
you're going to get
believers and nonbelievers.
And I think we've had a
good mix of that, for sure.
NICOLE KRASINSKI: For
probably the first 18 months,
there was a lot more skepticism,
and people didn't quite
understand why we were doing
it and what we were doing.
But once the ball
was rolling and we
were more publicly in
the press and people
understood what the goal
and the intention was,
we haven't really had anything--
any issues.
STUART BRIOZA: And
ironically, we never actually
called ourselves a
dim sum restaurant.
In the early days,
we were more kind
of akin to tapas
and small plates
and the idea of realizing
that we're not dim sum.
I mean, first, we're
serving dinner.
That completely challenges
the whole notion
of dim sum, which is
a daytime activity,
and it's food that's prepared
for tea service and whatnot.
But we actually have
never called ourselves--
it's gotten to that point
where other people have.
And we just go with it now.
Because it's like, why fight it?
That was about a year into it.
I think that when we looked
at the idea of dim sum,
dim sum was one function
of small plates.
And if you look at Japanese
izakaya, Spanish tapas,
Korean banchan--
all the banchan
that's on plates.
You look at mezz.
In Italy, there's kind of
this afternoon wine and snack
kind of--
I can't remember
the name right now.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
STUART BRIOZA: Huh?
STUART BRIOZA: Thank you.
That's it.
SPEAKER: Thank you, chef.
We looked at that, and we're
kind of a culmination of all
these-- the French
hors d'oeuvres party--
passing hors
d'oeuvres-- canapes.
We're a little bit of
all of those things.
And we looked at the Chinese
dim sum model as just purely
an efficiency model of being
able to deliver food quickly
on carts and trays.
We use a lot of
trays, actually--
more trays than carts.
But we, over time, have
incorporated more of our carts.
And we've redone our carts now.
And we do smaller
carts that can do--
I can have oysters out
and I can have a big--
NICOLE KRASINSKI: Chip and dip
STUART BRIOZA: --clay pot of
pork ribs or chip and dip.
So there's a little bit of
tableside activity as well.
The French have the
same type of cart.
It's called a gueridon.
And that's where your cheese
is rolled up to your table--
cheese or Bananas Foster--
some of the tableside
preparations-- or Caesar salad
done tableside.
So we looked at all
these ideas and kind of
took what we thought
were the best parts
and turned it to the dining
room and said, how can we
service the people best?
We know that tapas don't
work in this country.
It takes an entire country
and a culture of people that
are raised from the wee age--
three to five years old--
going and having a
little glass of wine
and moving from
tapas place to tapas
place because they all have
their little specialties,
and the food's in
the window there,
and you just kind
of grab and eat.
But when tapas was
brought to the US,
it was the coolest
thing ever, until nobody
realized that there was a--
how do you deliver food?
How do you know it's
enough food for the table?
A lot of chefs are
taking an entree
and basically putting it
through the shrinker machine
and charging 2/3 of
what the entree costs,
but giving you half as much.
There was a lot of
problems with it.
How do you break it down to
the lowest common denominator
so that everybody can
understand what they're doing?
And so we took that
tapas and put it
on wheels, and basically--
here, are you interested?
Cool. $6-- done.
Move on to the next.
You can see the portion size.
I can sell a lot of
weird food if I want to.
I can sell things
that people are like,
I don't even know what
we're talking about.
Like, you're speaking
a different language.
But they see it and it's
beautiful, and they'll take it.
We eat first with our eyes.
So we basically took the
functionality of all of that
and took a type of
cuisine that everybody
loves to eat-- small plates.
I hear it all the time.
I prefer to eat lots of little
dishes versus an entree.
SPEAKER: Everybody
wants more stuff.
STUART BRIOZA: You're
all shaking your head.
You're all agreeing with me--
shaking in agreement here.
Because you like that.
SPEAKER: All of the things.
Yeah, of course.
STUART BRIOZA: Korean
food is amazing,
because they kind of slaughter
you with kimchis and tofus
and cucumbers and sesame
oil and mung bean sprouts.
And you're getting
all your little things
and you're tasting.
And it's like you like all
the diversity of flavors.
Well, we just took
that same idea
and applied what I like to call
a little American ingenuity
to it to make it work
for the American diner
because tapas doesn't work.
And it doesn't make sense.
I'm confused, too.
Is that enough food?
And you've got to
ask your waiter.
And you've got to have this
dialogue where you just want
to do it yourself and figure it
out, where you're in control.
SPEAKER: So fantastic.
We are about to run out of
time for our amazing livestream
audience.
I know we have one
more question here
in the audience which we can
take as soon as the cameras
wrap.
But I want to thank
you officially
for our full audience,
online and here.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
I hope you'll come
back and see us again.
STUART BRIOZA: Well,
thanks for having us.
[APPLAUSE]